standard form here of an ellipses x
squared over a squared plus y squared
over B squared equals 1 so it always
equals 1 these terms are always added
and the a squared and the B squared can
be switched okay and we're going to talk
about okay the distance from the center
to the vertices okay that's the a
distance the distance from the center to
the co vertices okay that's where it's
narrower this is the minor axis this is
the major axis the major axis is the
longer axis so a distance to the major
vertices or they're just the vertices
that distance is a from the center from
the center to the minor vertices or Co
vertices along this minor or narrower
axis that distance is B and then the
distance from the center to the fossae
okay these two focal points that
distance is C okay so basically what an
ellipse is it's like this it's like if
you have a string and you hold down the
two ends of the string like this okay so
there's your string and you put your
pencil right in there and you pull that
string okay doesn't stretch but the
string will gradually get a little bit
longer here but a little bit shorter
here and then so on it's gonna get a
little bit longer here
shorter there if you take this piece
right here that kind of overlapped and
you cut it and you put it over here the
length of that string will be the length
of the major axis that's called the
focal distance okay or the focal length
and that's gonna be 2a okay which is the
length of the major axis okay so the a
okay if it's underneath the Y meaning
the larger quantity is underneath the Y
what that tells you it's gonna be more
elongated okay or stretched in the Y
direction the ellipse if the number
underneath the X is larger between the
two of these it's going to be more
elongated in the x axis direction like
the horizontal direction okay now just
like we work with parabolas with
shifting them you can shift these
ellipses as well so with using this H
and K so H and K is the center of the
ellipse so if there's not an H and K
like here it's going to be at the origin
okay so let's get into some problems and
I'll tell you little bit more about it
as we redo it so this first example we
have x squared over 25 plus y squared
over 9 equals 1 okay so if we go to
graph this
we can see that 25 equals a-squared okay
so what I'm going to do is in the
x-direction I'm going to go right 5 and
left 5 I'm just taking the square root
of 25 okay so we get 5 and we get
negative 5
okay so those are our vertices and then
if we take the square root of 9 we get 3
and negative 3 and it's easy to remember
because it's underneath the Y so it's
going to go in the Y direction the
vertical direction up three down three
so at this point we have a pretty good
graph you just draw an oval or an
ellipse okay
through those points but the only thing
we're missing is how to find the focal
points the full side and the way you do
that is use this formula here it's C
squared equals a squared minus B squared
okay so in this problem here it's going
to be C squared equals a squared that's
the larger of these two denominators
it's 25 minus 9 which equals 16 and if
we take the square root we get plus or
minus 4 so the full side are always
going to be along the longer axis the
major axis if it was longer in the
vertical direction we'd be going up and
down so I'm just going to go right for
and the left for those are the two full
side right there so if we were to tie
our string we would hold it down there
and that's what would trace out the
ellipse okay let's do another example
this one you can see the center is where
it's at positive 2 negative 3 right okay
so if we graph this one let's locate the
center right 2 up 3 okay like that and I
think I'm going to get myself a little
bit more room for this one so I'm just
gonna write draw it a little bit lower
okay so let's go down here so we've got
right 2 plus 3 2 down 3 okay so there's
your Center right there and then what
we're going to do is we're going to go
to in the X direction so let's square 2
4 is 2 so I'm going to go 2 to the right
of the center point so right 2 and left
two okay and I'm going to go in the Y
direction the square root of 36 so up 6
and down 6 so that's 4 5 6 okay right
there and then down 6 1 2 3 4 5 6 so
right about there okay oops I went a
little bit too far right there okay so
if you graph this
okay okay your lips is gonna look
something like that
okay so this is the major axis this is
the minor axis this is the center point
the only thing we have left to do is to
find the full side and we're gonna use
the same formula C squared equals a
squared minus B squared remember a
squared is the larger of these two
denominators so we have C squared equals
36 minus 4 which is 32 and if we take
the square root we get plus or minus
square root of 32 is 4 root 2 because 16
times 2 is 32 but what we want to do is
we want to go from the center point
which is to negative 3 but we're adding
4 root 2 and subtracting forward two
from the y coordinate since we're going
in a vertical direction so this is going
to be plus or minus 4 root 2 those are
the coordinates of the full side okay
all right so that's a little bit about
graphing now how about working backwards
where they give you some information and
you have to come up with your own
equation
well I still recommend drawing a sketch
that'll really help you to get all the
pieces together the a B and C so let's
go ahead and graph this ok so the
vertices are telling us our ad 2 3 and
at 2 negative 3 okay so here with me so
far so those are the vertices and we're
gonna need a little bit more information
here okay I just made this problem up
off the cuff here but let's just say
that the foci okay are at 2 2 and at 2
negative 2 okay so they're going to be
right here and right here okay so we can
see that our ellipse is going to look
something like this and we don't know
how wide it is yet but we're going to
figure that out using this formula here
C squared equals a squared minus B
squared so the distance from the center
okay which is halfway in between the
vertices so you can use the midpoint
formula or you can just count so this is
6 units halfway in between would be 3
units from either vertice or you can
find the midpoint of the foci halfway in
between those two focal points so we can
see the centers
to zero so this is going to be X minus
two squared plus y minus zero squared
equals one now we just have to find the
denominators okay it's longer in the
y-direction how do I know because the
vertices are along the major axis the
longer axis and the distance from the
center to the vertex is 3 so 3 squared
is 9 right because this is a squared
these terms are squared and now we just
have to find B squared well we know C
equals 2 that's the distance from the
center to the full side and we know a is
3 so if we put that into our formula we
get okay we get 2 2 squared is 4 3
squared is 9 and if you solve you can
see that B squared is going to be 5 so
this is 5 B